ma all salve ragazzi benvenute questo
nuovo video mi metto molto più a
sinistra in questo video perché qua
compare il mio telefono è per fare un
game penso che ogni tanto ti faccio
sempre sul telefono non è perché non ho
voglia di registrare al computer e
perché proprio non c'è voglia di
registrare computer e andiamo avanti
ogni tanto escono delle applicazioni che
meritano tipo questa va bene allora
vediamo se riusciamo a fare questa si
chiama milano non so me si apre in out
una roba del genere però ho visto che
tipo quel test del tontolone era un
botto che non faccio il test del dottore
pro a vedere come mi trovo su questo
spero bene perché ero bravino nei quiz
della potente la più grande le mie fanno
allora questo questo quanto ha la più
grande in che senso
lamela no cambiamo gioco ragazzo capace
la più grande e generale l'anguria
congratulazioni grazie mi stai dicendo
che sono l'intelligenza di un bebè cioè
ragione quante anatre allora contiamo
123456 sono persone euro pulcino
123456789 bravo dolcezza congratulazioni
dolcezza matica seguiti permette andiamo
avanti ragazzi chi è più alto galigani
altissimo ragazzi fatto sta foto
veramente altro che allora chi è più
alto di questi il sole hubble e reporter
brevi ed è che faccia non se l'aspettava
sagace ma perché che commenti inutili mi
sta facendo sto gioco successivo e
riesce a scoprire quello diverso
oddio non capisco mais e una domanda
seria o no comunque ma tanto se sbaglio
che succede niente
posso cliccar lì tutti volendo che lusso
mai quanto vi prende per il culo e
quanti ne quanto non lo stia facendo in
realtà non lo so ormai questo questo
si spostavano poiché a posto 6 brilla no
ma no è che sono catarifrangente andiamo
avanti comunque per ora è tutto a posto
sta andando tutto bene quale archivio è
simile all'artiglio peso del gatto non
sono attivi questi tra l'altro perché
non ha neanche le umili e stokr
dell'artiglio direi quale più simile
alla quale è simile perché gli altri
sono diversi allora l'uno e il 3 sono da
scartare perché sono rivolte verso
l'altra parte lehmann è proprio la mano
è rivolta alla nostra parte quindi
sbagliato ti direi tra il 24 quindi o il
24 di una mail due e rai 4 porte ma come
ma cosa va come amaro quello di fianco
mandata a parma o amo mia oh
ma chi è che fa ste cose spiegano c'è
anche questo e questo 10 11 11 dai 11
wheaton qui sono uscito con 60 bene
ragazzi bene sono un cielo so lo so non
mi capisce nessuno ma lo so il
coprifuoco più grande nave il fuoco più
grande e credo che sia dietro quello che
pupi poco più grande perché si possono
spostare se si possono spostare è perché
c'è qualcosa che non solo è più è grande
e più bello bravo come dice tua madre
qual è il numero sono bravo che scritto
quale senza posto per questo che il
genio parties che quale il numero sotto
l'auto parcheggiata e 09 volevi che si
vedrà attigue seigien francia bisogno di
quale voto daresti a questo gioco
giulia sveglia il gufo se avesse
funzionato mamma mia in 100 forse una
volta due imbarco si fa tagliare un
qualcuno mi ricordo non so chi e come
cacchio faccio a devo bruciarlo col sole
cioè il sole in faccia
devo togliere sono in modo che arrivi la
luna perché i gufi sono svegli giorno ok
ecco senso svegli di notte volo dire
perfetto grande il cervello hai un
cervello da genio me lo dite solo due
mia mamma bastano neanche mia madre a me
lo dice devi vincere tu la partita ok
proviamo come faccio tac a no dovevo
schiacciare insieme uno schiaccia con
due dita
congratulazioni ragazzo mi ha sgridato
perché giustamente ho fatto delle cose
giuste sta imbrogliando
no no per carità trova il colore più
scuro sullo schermo
il come più scuso schermo questo nero ma
scritta nera
[Musica]
capite perché comunque registrare a casa
mia non è proprio semplice
speriamo tu perché sono le scarpine vedi
registrare parco demonio conta il numero
di capelli qua ragazzi potrei dire un
miliardo 33
lo scrisse volevo volo sbagliare perché
sarebbe stato figo scriverlo così però
va bene lo stesso tre le aiuterà trucco
a bere dell'acqua questo caso talmente
stupido che le capisco
mi ricorda la storia dei corpi che
dovevano l'acqua non ce lo presenta e
non la voglio sapere perché a risolvere
questo quesito 1 più
non sto capendo che capire se non lo so
perché non ho capito cosa devo fare
a ro 2 devo ammetterlo qua ok cosa che
non ho capito niente sta migliorando
sempre di prima perché sono bravo perché
ho studiato perché sono uscito 60 perché
mi vogliono la patente
tutto insieme ragazzi metti la giraffa
nel frigorifero metto il frigorifero
nella girata nei
apriti allora eccolo hai capito
eccellente grazie aiuto la giraffa a
mangiare la mela
adesso stanno diventando delle cazzate
estreme prima erano veramente logici
adesso sta veramente diventando la cosa
non mi sponsorizzare un gioco dove c'e
un ragno perché non lo scaricare neanche
a pagamento cioè nel senso semi pagarsi
to capito quello solito vietato fumare a
dove rimpicciolire la sigaretta
scommette ma dove ingrandire questo no
devo ingrandire cui devo ingrandirne 1
ma non ho capito quale hanno spinto la
si chiama time ha veramente ora non
fumare
no io non ho mai giocato sigarette avete
quello mettendo tre monete nel
salvadanaio quante volete ci sono ora
sempre tre perché non le mettono no non
è così tante monete ci sono ora che
senso ce n'è una procede 2 e quale nei
tre sempre tre sono porco demaniali sono
messi è stato adana io devo rompere il
salvadanaio ecco lo sapevo
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 13 15 demonio
porco ma l'avrei mai azzeccato hai fatto
molto bene da fuori di andare a
tentativi non avrei giocato mai dovuto
romperlo per forza grazie famiglia deve
sempre ragni
vabbè praga all'ultima veramente
l'ultima perché sono allora 1 2 3 5 6 9
ragazzi o completamente sparato h però
questa è la storia della mia vita in
realtà quindi chi mi conosce lo sa
vivo di questo i ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto fateci avere se
volete l'altra bisogno di prince out sul
serio ragazzi mi sembra molto carino
però che vede sempre cento ragazzi
iscritti al canale si esce dalla campo
alle linea con i rimanenti sono i video
che escono e no è come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo vi do un bacino e come
sempre più belle ragazze
[Musica]